[Music]
is investigating the suspect's possible
links to radical Islam at the same time
City officials are not on the same page
as they send conflicting messages about
a motive the mayor says the Muslim faith
has nothing to do with it while the
police point out it could be a major
factor in no way shape or form does
anyone in this room believe that Islam
or the teaching of Islam has any
anything to do which you've seen on that
screen that is apparent it's it's just
it's terrible and it does not represent
the religion in any way shape or form or
any of its teachings he stated that he
pledges his allegiance to Islamic State
he follows Allah and that is the reason
he was called upon to do
this and joining us now with some
reaction Robert Spencer who is the
director of jihad watchat and author of
the book The Complete infidels guide to
Isis welcome sir great to have you on
the program today thank you I'm a great
to be here you know it's remarkable that
we had these two news conferences just
minutes apart and between the mayor and
the police chief two very different
messages there and it looks like
politics is now getting into the threat
assessment even with an apparent
confession from the suspect why do you
think the mayor is bound in determin to
relabel the
crime well this happens every time
there's a Jihad attack we see Barack
Obama or whatever relevant local
official immediately say we have to
understand that this has nothing to do
with Islam it seems as if if their first
priority is not protecting Americans but
protecting the image of Islam now that's
absolutely ridiculous in point of fact
the Islamic state has called for exactly
this kind of attack they have said that
they want Muslims in the United States
to attack particularly police and
Military Officers as well as civilians
in Lone Wolf attacks of exactly this
kind for the mayor to deny that there's
any Islamic connection is like saying
well in 1941 some Japanese men attacked
Pearl Harbor we're still trying to
figure out their motive the motive is
very plain and what we need to start to
investigate is what is the motive of the
mayor of Philadelphia and other
politicians like him in denying what is
so obvious you know you mentioned um the
directive has been given out by some of
the terrorist networks out there to go
and shoot uh police officers and
servicemen and women uh this comes right
out of their playbook doesn't it oh
absolutely they have a very detailed
Playbook on attacking American civilians
on blending into American Society on
appearing to be moderate you see in the
film that this man was wearing Islamic
dress actually the Islamic State
generally says don't wear Islamic dress
and we know that Edward archer in other
photographs is not wearing it and he's
blending in with the society exactly as
the Islamic State directs don't carry
around a Quran don't go to mosque and of
course the mosque is saying that they
don't know this guy but his mother says
that he was quite quite devout and so
there needs to be a mature investigation
by the Philadelphia authorities into
whether he was following exactly this
Isis Playbook since he seems to have
been following it out to the tea you
know we haven't heard any real reaction
from the White House about the shooting
and there are those who are saying that
the authori should really be looking at
the ideology of radical Islam and how it
it's uh how to counter the impact it has
with folks who do want to do us
harm absolutely this is the gravest
omission of this entire conflict that
the one side the whole side of the Free
World is in complete denial about the
ideological nature of this conflict and
we have this man right here who says
this is Isis this is an attack based on
the directives of the Islamic State and
the me first thing that the Philadelphia
authorities say is no it isn't and look
we are setting ourselves up for defeat
that way you can't defeat an enemy you
don't understand much less an enemy you
refuse to understand and that's the
position our authorities are putting
ourselves into I want to shift GE just a
little bit uh here and but talking about
keeping with the subject in terms of the
spread of uh Global terrorism the
situation that has lots of folks upset
right now the apparent coordinated
assaults against women on New Year's Eve
by Asylum seekers in Germany Finland and
other European countries why do you
believe the news was kept under the
radar until just a couple of days ago
because we're seeing today protests from
German citizens about the way the
authorities there have been handling
this and trying to downplay the impact
of those assaults your reaction I think
in both cases in the Philadelphia case
and in the case of the sex assaults in
the European cities the reason why this
was downplayed or covered up was because
it indicts the policies of the the
politicians in power as well as the
media that's been supporting them down
the line uh they've been letting in into
Europe these hundreds of thousands of
Muslim immigrants Muslim migrants
without any regard for the fact that the
Islamic State said in February that they
were going to flood Europe with 500,000
refugees and that there's no way to
determine Islamic jihadis among them
there's no way to distinguish the
jihadis from peaceful Muslims among the
refugees so if they acknowledge that
these sexual assaults happen on such a
large scale in Germany and elsewhere
they're inditing their own policies the
policies that the media has put forward
the policies that the politicians are
unanimously in favor of and if the
Philadelphia mayor says that that had to
do with Islam he also is inditing the
same immigration policies of Barack
Obama and the policies in regard to
domestic Muslims that he's not
challenging them to stand up in more
firm and honest ways against the Jihad
ideology Robert fencer great to have you
on the show today thank you so much for
joining us we really appreciate it thank
you